hey everyone dear volume here and in
today's video we're going to be going
over each and every main member of the
tokyo manji gang this will consist of us
going over each of the five captains and
their vice captains
explaining a little bit about them and
then finally at the end of the video we
will go over draken and the invincible
mikey but before we get into all of that
if you are new around here and want to
keep up to date with the latest tokyo
avengers content and more then make sure
you hit that subscribe button
and also if you do enjoy my videos then
make sure you hit that like button as it
really helps out with the algorithm and
pushes my content to a bunch of
new amazing people but enough of that
let's get into the video
so first let's go over the first
division captains and their vice
presidents respectively
there have been a total of three
different first division captains
the first were two co-captains during
the beginning of tournament before
people had their proper
respective divisions this division
formerly called the attack unit was
co-led by kazutora hanemiya and kasuki
baji
kazutori hanemiya was one of the six
founders of tomen and the captain
of the first division along with bhaji
due to an incident that happened after
they started the tokyo manji gang
kazitoro was sentenced to 10 years in
juvenile prison and is only seen a few
times in the timelines where takamichi
has returned to being an adult and in
flashbacks to the beginning of tomin he
is 15 years old at the start of the
series and 27
in the present timeline his name
kazutora means one tiger which is in
reference to the tiger tattoo that he
has on the side of his neck
bhaji is also another one of the six
founding members of tomen and the main
reason for the creation of the gang
he was initially the co-captain of
division one along with the previously
mentioned kazutora then he moved into
the position as its captain after
kazutoro was sentenced to juvi baji
is 15 years old in his series and is
either seen with his long black hair
left free-flowing or tied up in a
ponytail on other occasions
bhaji is extremely loyal to tomen and
his friends but would do absolutely
anything for kazutora as we saw
throughout the vahalla arc
takamichi hanagaki is the main character
of tokyo revenges and after a ton of
hard work becomes the first division
captain of the tokyo manji gang
although takamichi isn't one of the
founders of the group he grows into a
position
where all of the founding members see
him as someone they can look to when
they need help he is 14 in the past and
26 in the future timeline making him one
of the younger members in the gang
shifuyu is the vice president of the
first division under takamichi he
becomes an extremely close friend with
takamichi throughout the series his
blonde hair is 14 years old in the
present timeline and 26 years old in the
future timeline
now that we've gone over all the
captains and vice captains of the first
division of the tokyo manji gang we can
move on to division two division ii has
been held by one captain and one vice
captain throughout the entirety of this
series never been replaced this is the
fashion designer takashi matsuya and his
vice captain hikai shiva the second
division was first designated as the
gang's elite guard meant to protect
mikey
takashi mitsuya is the president of the
second division of tomen and the older
brother of two sisters mana and luna and
the designer of the tokyo revenge's
uniform
metuhya is also one of the founding six
members of tomen and
is currently 15 years old in the anime
making him 27 years old in takamichi's
future timelines
hikaishiba is the vice president of
tomen's second division and the younger
brother of taichu and yuzu hashiba
despite his large size hakai is
extremely timid and a very friendly guy
a guy comes from a wealthy family which
earns him the so-called narity as the
money bags of the tokyo avengers
he is slightly younger than takamichi by
a few months but is still 14 and 26
in respective timelines behind division
two is obviously
the third division known as the flag
bearers of the gang
although it does look like this division
specialises in strength and straight
brute force
as well this division is initially led
by haruki hayashida or just parshin
and rohei hayashi better known as payan
who was still vice president but after
passing risk hisaki ends up taking his
position
much to the disappointment of takamichi
though for this video i'm just going to
be going over parchin and payan if
you're interested in knowing more about
kasaki tessa then be sure to check out
my video on who he is and how
insane he really is parchin is a
founding member of the tokyo manji gang
and the captain of the third division
although he is currently spending two
years in juvenile prison for his actions
during the mobius and tomen incident he
is 15 years old currently
making him also 27 in the original
timeline
even though he seemed extremely
aggressive at first he is actually an
extremely cheerful and nice person who
even admits that his previous actions
were stupid
payan is the best friend and vice
president of parchin's third division
after some incidents that occur
throughout the first two arcs of this
story payan is made into the standing
third division captain until the return
of parchin from juvi
i find payan to be an extremely
aggressive character but as someone who
cares
for his close friends and would do
anything for them he is also 15 years
old in the past timeline and 27 and the
future one
division iv is the most mysterious
division as hardly anything is known
about it
what is known though is that it is
currently run by the twins nahoya and
sota kawata most well known as smiley
and angry who are big fan favorites of
people who are up to date with the manga
smiley is the captain of division iv and
is one of the older members of the group
coming in at 16
in the past and 28 in the future
timelines he is a very bubbly character
and one that is extremely lovely to just
have around though you never want to get
on the wrong side of smiley as if you do
you can pretty much just call it quits
because you'll have to deal with the man
himself
angry angry is the younger brother of
smiley and vice president of division
iv and tomen though he seems extremely
angry hence the name he is actually very
kind and considers himself a pacifist
however once something unfair or very
dangerous happens to one of his close
friends or brother
he starts to cry out and rage and
according to nahoya once
in the stay of the crying blue ogre he
would be considered 100 times stronger
than smiley himself angry is
also 16 and 28 in respective timelines
the fifth and final division is a
different type of division than all
others in the gang
led by yoshihiro muto this division was
made before takamichi joined but at a
currently unknown time
this division allows infighting as a
special division force they are allowed
to go behind mikey and the other
captains to attack a member if they
think they are possibly a traitor this
is considered the public morality
council
yoshihiro moto is like of said the
captain of division five he was born two
years before the older members of toman
and is considered part of the
s62 generation which is considered the
worst generation of delinquents
and he met some of the atonement members
after spending time in juvenile
detention for breaking the spine of
someone he is currently 18 years old and
30 in future timelines harichiro sanzu
santo is an extremely mysterious
character and the main reason i decide i
decided to include division five as
someone who is still a key player in the
current fontaine arc as the number two
he is an extremely mysterious but
dangerous figure at the same time with
the nickname or alias
the loyal mad dog i think it states it
all is the vice president of division 5
he is 15 years old when he is introduced
into the story and 27
in his respective future timelines
taking the spot as the number two and
the tokyo manji gang is the infamous ken
ryoguji
draken is the vice leader of tomen and
mikey's best and closest friend in the
series
draken is an extremely wild person with
a heart of gold who is extremely loyal
to mikey and tries his best to guide him
at the start of the series he is 15
years old like the majority of the toman
members
and 27 in his future timeline finally
the leader of tomen and probably my
favorite character in the series
manjuro sano better known as just the
invincible mikey
mikey is one of the most in-depth and
interesting characters in the entire
story
who's initially hard to analyse due to
his so-called dark impulses that always
seem to get a hold of him
he is 15 when he first meets takamichi
and 27 when naoto introduces him
along with kisaki to us in the first
chapters there is also a sixth division
that comes about after a while
but for now i'm just going to stick with
the core five divisions that have stuck
with
us throughout the entirety of the manga
and who you're going to see
introduced throughout the second half of
the first season if you want me to go
over more specific characters in depth
then chuck a comment down below with who
you'd like as this video is an extremely
quick one bringing people in the anime
and summon the manga
up to date with all the presidents and
vice presidents of the tokyo manji gang
and not really going into too much depth
if you have enjoyed the video and enjoy
tokyo avengers in general then make sure
you hit that like button and if you are
new around here and want to keep up to
date with the latest anime content then
make sure you hit that subscribe button
but anyway
enough of that for now it's been your
professional degenerate diavolo and i'll
see you all in a bit
[Music]
bye
you